[Music]
[Music]
staying on
hey miss Bunsen if you find this
recording don't feel bad about this part
of the journey is the end
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue as
more fun that sounds food water ran out
four days ago
officers shall run out tomorrow morning
I've been when I drift off I will dream
about you it's always you
[Music]
danos did exactly what he said he was
gonna do
he wiped out 50% of all living creatures
we lost all of us
lost friends lost family
we lost a part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
hi is anyone home this is Scott Lang we
met a few years ago at the airport in
Germany that got really big it's just an
old message I know you know that's
suspect oh that's me
can you buzz me in
hello
is anyone there
I'm trying to reach
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
senators we believe that these Titans
are just the tip of the iceberg which of
these Titans are here to protect us and
which of these Titans are here to
threaten us
so you'd want to make Godzilla our pet
no we would be his you sure he's gonna
be okay
they're everywhere battling for
dominance
arrival alpha to Godzilla so gotta be
kid
[Music]
[Music]
Jonathan what have you done
[Music]
there's no escape for you the high table
wants your life
tell me what you want person I can't
help you to reach the unreachable
you expecting to meet ours a 40 million
dollar bounty on his head
never would the city wants a piece of it
I say the author about even dark to five
seconds
Charlie
in effect in three two one
[Music]
and the way we go
[Music]
[Music]
Sophia we're not going in like the old
days just a conversation nothing's ever
just a conversation with you John
[Music]
[Music]
they warned us that something was coming
if there is ever an end in this forever
war it will be because of you
and your strong right hand where the
line in the sand we fight against the
forces of darkness this is the earth
you're expecting a sign that says secret
headquarters oh I need some ID love um
are you serious
[Music]
made me a damn weapon I just wanted to
help you become the best you
[Applause]
some dads get their kids Legos saving
the world or something
does it do anything special yeah
it smashes things real good
[Music]
you are mankind's best and only hope
especially fighting monsters not working
with them
are you calling monster pal you look let
me recently
for us
but the country is arrived just in time
[Music]
always remember the universe has a way
of leading into where you're supposed to
be at the moment you're supposed to be
there let's do this took me 20 years to
find you
how many people can say that
you are the best-kept secret in the
universe and I found you
which makes be perfect for this job you
really think a black suit he's going to
solve all your problems
no but looks damn good on you we
[Music]
recognizable only as deja vu and
dismissed just as quick keep trying to
prove yourself agent M welcome to my
Beach you will be with Asian treats one
of the best ever to weather suit
[Music]
catching up for my daily meditation time
for lunch oh thank you hungry it's 9:30
Tuesdays taco day we've been compromised
Oprah's every citizen of this planet at
risk
[Applause]
if you could all just look right here
just try
gonna be fun left fun with it
there should be a big red button around
here somewhere found it we are the men
in black
we're so good
beep sorry I'm late happy look nice
thank you you too thank you new dress
yes it is hot you know what just
happened
a trip to Europe
[Music]
let's get your passport Peter Parker
here to pick up a passport please
ladies face let's pack your suit I just
want to go on my trip with my friends
Europe doesn't really need it from the
neighborhoods
[Music]
you look really pretty therefore I have
value no it's not I'm messing with you
you look pretty too I'll do my personal
love I just finished my phone coffee so
nice to finally meet you
in spite of man
your Nick Fury what's he clothes on
let's go for a ride is she gonna be okay
like that might want to turn him over so
he doesn't swallow his tongue
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
get gifts Parker but we have a job to do
are you going to step up or not
you're all alone your friends are in
trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one
he's no spider-man what is it with you
and spider-man what he looks out for the
neighbor it has a dope suit and I really
respect him
sup dickwad you think you can fix me gee
you are not broken
beautiful friend mind is a fragile thing
takes only the slightest tap to tip it
in the wrong direction
Charles what did you do I had to keep a
stable I protected her from the truth
there's another word for them I came
looking for answers you feel like you
don't belong here
you don't they can't begin to comprehend
what you are she's changing what you
didn't come here looking for answers you
came here looking for permission she's
range
Hey missile coming out of us Jean lost
control is she still a Fed this is your
fault Charles the world is on the brink
I'm sorry
I didn't stop it sooner you're always
sorry Charles
and as always a speech and nobody cares
there still
don't do this
[Music]
the right to fear me I've seen Abel
[Music]
I'm looking at it now so scrolls are the
bad guys
and you're a Cree a race of noble
warriors heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior
you were reborn
I keep having these
memories something in my past is the key
to all of this
you know how to fly this thing you'll
see
that's a yes or no question yes
[Music]
would you like to know
what you really are
[Music]
I think I had a life here
what aren't you telling me
we've come a long way
but you know as strong as you think
[Music]
thus for just the beginning
I'm not gonna fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
I've seen acute is lovely are you what's
your name
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can't take care of myself
when you're 18 give these people a
chance cuz that's what they're giving
you this is Billy Batson make sure you
make him feel at home they seem nice but
don't buy it it gets real Game of
Thrones around here dude just mess
around you look at me and you're like
why so dark you're disabled foster kid
you've got it all if you could have one
superpower what would you think
everybody chooses flight you know why so
they can fly away from this conversation
no cuz heroes fly well you hear your
fake family to stand up for you
man sorry about that
baby backs I choose you
that's a peon
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir
wait for you okay
Shazam
really you're the only person I know
that knows anything about this Cape
Crusader stuff tonight what are your
superpowers superpowers dude I don't
even know how to pee in this thing okay
why are you talking guards your phone
charged like a bad guy right
you have full immunity
wolfram you're dead sorry about your
window yeah welcome for not getting
robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
welcome to rhyming city a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct if you were anything like your
talent
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah
yeah that didn't really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are I know how
to use this jeez
here we go I know you can't understand
me but put down the stapler or I will
electrocute you did you just talk whoa
did you just understand me oh my god you
can understand me I've been so lonely
they tried to talk to me all the time
all they hear is pika pika you can hear
him right guys adorable you're adorable
they can't understand me kiss you no one
else here
I told me to Pokemon period and what
about a world-class detective because if
you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
magic that brought us together and that
magic key is called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine yeah tell us what we want to
know hi yes okay I can shoving pushing
my problem is that I push people away
and then hate them for leaving he's
saying you can shove it what I can shove
it okay that's it no we're switching
roles I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
[Music]
does it bother you that I'm not
completely human you were the most human
person I have ever met
[Music]
didn't I tell you to be home before dark
I just lost track of time
Alida you have to be responsible where's
someone very special hey kid
not just a teenage girl hey what's your
problem you can't remember what do you
mean doc found you in the scrap yard so
you must be from up there and I'm just
an insignificant girl that's what they
want you to think
I'm not your daughter I don't know what
I am
I do yet the most advanced weapon ever
but that's just a shell
it's not bad or good that part's up to
you
I do not stand by
in the presence of evil
she's threatening the natural order of
things
tonight is not a game
it is a heart
I need you to destroy the girl called
Aleta
you'd be the biggest mistake of your
life
and what's that
under estimating Who I am
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]